Are you looking to upgrade your microscope?
Well microcosmos.store is the place for you!
We’ve got a selection of plan achromatic
objectives ranging from 4x all the way up
to 100x, and these objectives don’t just
work on The Microcosmos Microscope.
They will also work on other DIN-standard
compound microscopes.
Because of the way lenses are made, regular
achromatic objectives display a curved image
which results in the edges of the field of
view being slightly distorted and out of focus.
But these plan objectives produce a flatter
image across the entire field of view, resulting
in an overall sharper image, which is great
if, like us, you enjoy capturing pictures
and videos of your samples.
So go to microcosmos.store if you want to
upgrade your objectives or pick up any other
Microcosmos merchandise.
In 1864, Louis Pasteur stood up in front of
a crowd at the Sorbonne Scientific Soiree
to deliver an address.
And he started by saying:
"A number of imposing problems now have our
best minds in thrall."
Those imposing questions covered everything
from the history of humankind to the concept
of species, but Pasteur promised the crowd
he would not be answering any of those questions.
What Pasteur wanted to address was a question
much more fundamental.
Can life be created spontaneously?
The concept Pasteur wanted to discuss was
called spontaneous generation, which posited
that perhaps living things could just like appear
from some other kind of matter, though there
were various ideas about exactly how that
could work.
It was an old theory, and it took several
century's worth of experiments to prove that
it was wrong.
Unfortunately, we of course do not have
footage of these experiments.
But a year and a half ago, our master of microscopes,
James, was inspired by the idea of spontaneous
generation and set up his own experiment.
He cut a plastic bottle in half, and flipped
the top half so he could place it in the bottom
half like a funnel and keep it from spilling.
Then he placed his contraption outside to
see what would show up.
The plan was to return a few weeks later,
but…
he forgot.
And in his defense, he had a lot of other
microbes to watch.
When James eventually remembered and went
to check on it, he found brownish residue
and a bunch of dead bugs on the bottom of
the bottle.
And of course, because he’s James, the first
thing he did was put it under the microscope
so we could all see the array of microscopic
creatures dwelling within.
The question that spontaneous generation sought
to answer is how those creatures got into
that bottle.
And there were several ideas around how life
could spontaneously generate.
One theory, called abiogenesis, believed that
life could arise from nonliving matter, like
scallops forming from the sand they’re found
in.
Another theory was called heterogenesis, and
it suggested that life could form from another
species that was living, or that had once
been living—
like insects that show up out of nowhere on
decaying flesh.
Aristotle describes both of these theories
of spontaneous generation in his treatise
The History of Animals, but he was not the
first or only person to believe in spontaneous
generation.
In Pasteur’s speech, he described an old
recipe to make mice.
Simply add a dirty shirt to a vessel filled
with wheat grains and then wait 21 days.
At the end of the waiting period, you will
find the wheat transformed into mice.
It’s easy enough to laugh at these ideas now.
Like we know how cells work, and that
they exist, and how they reproduce
and pass along a life encoded in
DNA that in turn begets more life.
And as we watch the creatures from James’
bottle floating across our screen, we know
enough about microbes to know how they got
there.
Many of them were in the air, making up an
invisible universe that found its way into
the bottle through rain or wind or some other
element.
But if you lived in a world where you did not
know that microbes can travel through the
air, James’ experiment would be much harder
to interpret.
Are there really unseen creatures traveling an
imperceptible path all around us in the air and the rain
Or are they the product of a chemical reaction
we just haven’t found the formula to yet?
On its own, this bottle can’t find the explanation.
In fact, no single experiment could resolve
the spontaneous generation debate.
Every experiment performed was in conversation
with the experiments and ideas that came before it.
And each experiment set the scene for the
work that followed.
For example, in the middle of the 17th century,
an Italian scientist named Francesco Redi
put meat in sealed jars to demonstrate that
maggots did not spontaneously generate from
decaying flesh.
But while his experiment helped people understand
that maggots come from very small eggs, other
advances complicated matters,
including our favorite invention, the microscope.
In Pasteur’s words:
But at the end of the seventeenth century,
a tremendous discovery, that of the microscope,
revealed an entire new world to Man, the world
of the infinitesimally small.
So while it had, most assuredly, been vanquished
as far as the higher creatures were concerned,
the doctrine of spontaneous generation now
reappeared, audaciously declaring:
Here is my province!
Microbes are small and often associated with
decaying matter, so they provided a new vessel
for the ideas of spontaneous generation and
heterogenesis.
In the middle of the 18th century, one English
biologist named John Needham set out to investigate
the spontaneous generation of microbes by
boiling broth.
The aim was to kill whatever was living in
there so that after the broth cooled down
and was then sealed, he could compare it to
another flask of broth that had not been heated.
When Needham found that both the unheated
and heated broths turned cloudy, he concluded
that microbes must have spontaneously generated
in those flasks.
How else could they get there?
Well we know the answer,
and we are seeing it in action now:
there are microbes in the air that found
their way into the experiment.
But remember, we did not know
this at the time.
But Lazzaro Spallanzani, an Italian biologist,
had an inkling that this could be the case,
and that perhaps there were microbes in the
air contaminating Needham’s flasks.
So Spallanzani repeated the experiment, but
in a way where he could seal the flask before
boiling it.
And under Spallanzani’s conditions, no microbes
appeared.
This seems like a blow for
spontaneous generation.
But as scientists better understood the importance
of oxygen to cellular respiration, some began
to wonder if Spallanzani was wrong.
What if microbes could spontaneously generate,
just not in the air-deprived environment he
had created?
Scientists went back and forth over whether
this was the case, engaging in a dialogue
told through different experimental set-ups.
But by the time Pasteur took the stage, none
of the experiments before him on either side
could fully seal the holes in their argument.
Pasteur disagreed with the theory of spontaneous
generation, and he decided to test his ideas
by building on the same premise that many
of his predecessors had used in their experiments:
kill off the organisms in a flask and watch
to see if anything grows.
But he needed to prevent contamination from
any organisms potentially flying through the
air, while also ensuring that there was air
present to nourish organisms if they did manage
to spontaneously generate in the broth.
This was kind of a complicated and contradictory
set of parameters for an experiment, and Pasteur
found an elegant solution.
He bent the neck of a flask into an S, creating
a swan-like shape.
After Pasteur boiled the nutrient broth in
the flask and killed the organisms within
it, the s-shaped neck allowed air to flow
through.
But Pasteur thought the shape would make it
hard for particles traveling in the air to
get into the broth, trapping microbes before
they could get into the flask.
And so it was not a surprise to him that the
broth remained clear, uncontaminated by microbes.
Pasteur however, was not done.
He wanted to see if the microbes he expected
to be trapped in the neck of the flask were
really there.
So he tipped the flask to the side and allowed
the broth to reach into the s-shape.
When he did that, the broth eventually
became cloudy.
He had shown that his broth did not fill with
microbes spontaneously.
Pasteur gets much of the credit for disproving
spontaneous generation, maybe in part because
it fed into his understanding of fermentation
and the germ theory of disease.
And when we lay out the story like this, the
path to his discovery seems kind of linear.
One experiment begets another, which begets
another, and so on—
flask after flask made murky with microbes
like the bottle James set up in his backyard.
But there are so many figures missing from
our telling of this story, like John Tyndall,
the Irish physicist who investigated and validated
Pasteur’s theories, or Pasteur’s opposition,
like the pathologist Henry Charlton Bastian.
And there are so many more characters and
conversations of varied forms and tones that
shaped the way this science was done and the
conclusions that were drawn.
Because ultimately, the uncovering of
knowledge is a very human affair—
a search for beginnings buried in a hidden
world, a treasure hunt with many treasures,
but no end in sight.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
These folks here are our Patreon patrons.
If you put them in a flask and boil it, I
would be so mad at you.
How would we make this show without them?
It's not like they spontaneously generate.
They are individual people making individual
decisions because they want things like this
to exist on the Internet.
Thank you so much to all of them.
And if you would like to see your name here,
you can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro where
you can also find out about some of the cool
perks you can get!
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.